hello i'm so excited to meet you
i'm so excited to meet you i'm
fangirling over here so
um i've i've been wanting to like i
don't know
hang out yeah i i've always wanted to
see you live and the closest i got was
when you performed
uh in the finale at um american idol and
you were pregnant and you sang piece by
piece
yeah because i felt like i was there
with you oh i sat
alone in my kitchen yeah crying ugly
crying in my sweatpants
and my daughter walked in and she caught
me and she was like
what are you doing she could not put it
together that i would be just crying
that hard
oh my gosh no i'm so emotional man i
mean
you'll get this just being pregnant like
especially at the tail end i was about
to pop
i was so emotional and then like
beautiful and literally they it was
supposed to be the end they weren't
bringing it back no one knew that so
it's supposed to be the end of it it was
my start and i was so overwhelmed it was
so bad
anyway thank you for crying with me so
beautiful
and so honest oh thank you that's why i
love you so much because you are you're
so beautiful and so honest i could keep
going this could just be this the whole
time but
oh my gosh yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever